all right new rule for the nfl as of
2022 a secondary helmet is permitted one
important caveat though
if you need the uniform to go along with
the secondary helmet it's too late to
have the uniform ready for 2022. so
we may not see some of these until 2023
but our draft today best helmets
for uh secondary purposes
trivia question who holds the bears
franchise record for interceptions
thrown big cat
is it are you doing this to hurt my
feelings
no
no testing your knowledge of your
favorite team is it is it either you
know
[Music]
yeah and it was the old days back when
they had a lot of interceptions yeah
even close they used to have a lot of
interceptions in football all right uh
first pick for me it's it's the the
buccaneers the creamsicles we're not
going to see them until 23. but without
question i love there's so i don't know
a great pick and nostalgia listen let me
enjoy let me enjoy the time there was a
world before you were born the tampa bay
buccaneers were part of that world they
were part of my world they were
beautiful i want them back all right go
ahead you're up okay uh mine is i can't
believe you didn't go to number one here
the best ones kelly green philadelphia
eagles
i like those not as a first first-round
pick but i do like those and they should
go back to that they should go back to
that as their regular uniform there's
been 20 years of this other weird dark
green with the the weird numbers they
should go back to that that should be
their base uniform not an alternate
uniform pat patriot second round final
answer bring it back 2023 wouldn't it be
great if somehow and it's not going to
happen this year obviously but the next
time the bucks and the patriots play
four years from now when tom brady is
still playing they'll have bucko bruce
and pat patriot when they square off
that's what that would be something all
right you left you literally left the
best two helmets on on the board no i
didn't i took the best two no you didn't
the broncos light blue is is the best
that that is incredible that's an
incredible helmet that one i'm very very
excited for look at that with the big d
come on
that is i just dumb i dominated you and
i still have a pick left
mike florio use think at draft
let me let me explain this we likely
will see that one in 2022 because the
broncos already use the old logo on
their dark blue helmet as their color
rush uniform anyway so they don't need
they don't need to be able to submit
plans for a new uniform to go with the
helmet i suspect that they'll have that
now they have to let everyone know by
july 31 what they're going to do but i
suspect to see that on the field in
2022. next one for me and this isn't
throwback this is this is fast forward
this is the bengals going with the white
helmet to go with their white on white
uniform the white siberian tiger uniform
for the bengals that
is the one that you should have taken
with your first two picks no you're not
thinking forward you're thinking
backward wait until the bengals do it
everyone is going to lose their minds
and they'll still be the bengals
oh yeah
yes there's a cool thing
you need so who gets the oilers blue
helmets those cool those cool throwbacks
who gets that titans titans titans not
the texans easy that's an easy pick
another beautiful beautiful helm look at
that helmet come on mike that's a good
one
do you prefer the white do you prefer
the white or the blue give me both they
can do they can do the white now
right
right now they just peel the they peel
off the the decals and put those on yeah
they have dark helmets that's right they
got they got the that's right they got
the bowling ball helmets now i forgot
that the titans got rid of their white
helmets so yeah they could either one is
an alternate helmet they're gonna have
to pick one of the others so you want
white or you want blue let me know so i
can look like you know what you prefer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports